cupboards of the 38 studios scandal two
years after Curt Schilling's company
came to Rhode Island that the promise of
a big loan backed by your tax dollars
the video game developer is finished all
of a sudden suddenly without warning
there's like financial damnation in
there out of business I don't know what
happened down there the bankruptcy of
video game developer 38 studios wasn't
just a startup tech company falling
victim to the vagaries of a rough
economy it was a completely predictable
boondoggle of crony capitalism created
by starstruck legislators and the hubris
of a larger-than-life athlete completely
unprepared to compete in business former
Boston Red Sox pitcher Curt Schilling
and iconic figure in New England after
anchoring a historic playoff comeback
which ended an 86 year title drought
founded 38 studios near the end of his
baseball career in the hopes of becoming
a major player in the massively
multiplayer gaming world Schilling
invested millions of his own fortune in
the company and with the self-assured
bravado he exhibited as a player set out
on finding investors to infuse his
company with the roughly 50 million
dollars needed to complete 38 studios
first game although Curt Schilling is
the kind of local legend who could get a
meeting with every venture capitalist in
New England one after the other
Massachusetts VCS passed on 38 studios a
venture capitalists told the Wall Street
Journal that it would have taken a lot
of babysitting to do a deal with
Schilling because he was an experienced
than the management team was an
experienced Schilling went to Governor
Deval Patrick in Massachusetts he's a
Democrat and asked for some sort of
support and the Patrick administration
had very little interest in it it was
surprising that Curt Schilling being
known here as a Republican he was
campaigning with President Bush shortly
after the Red Sox won the World Series
as a small government guy to be going to
the government for his private business
the company never got a major private
investor on board other than the state
of Rhode Island Rhode Island governor
Donald khechari term limited and
searching for a legacy made it his
mission to her 38 studios from
Massachusetts to Rhode Island his pitch
included a 75 million dollar loan it's
all against the backdrop of a horrific
economy in Rhode Island we have
double-digit unemployment still as we're
speaking today in 2012 we started losing
jobs in early 2007 before the rest of
the country really felt the hit of the
Great Recession there was a desperation
by 20
tend to do something it was will get 450
new jobs in Rhode Island
there isn't much risk the taxpayers
we're told to do this deal because the
the company would thrive and they pay
back the loan Governor khechari also
served as chairman of the board of the
Rhode Island Economic Development
Corporation a quasi public agency whose
mission is to promote business in the
state with the authority to dole out
public dollars to private ventures in
the interests of stimulating the economy
however each loan guarantee must be
approved by the Rhode Island legislature
only one lawmaker voted against the loan
representative Bob Watson it was a
program that was too fast too loose and
frankly a scandal waiting to happen
there were a lot of red flags as it
relates to 38 studios few people of any
took note of the fact that Curt
Schilling had no background no
experience few people if any took note
of the fact that this was a speculative
market very risky there is that cynicism
in me anytime I see vast amounts of
public taxpayer money being put to use
for private ventures and certainly
politicians more often than not very
poor when it comes to making business
decisions it would be easy for people to
think that this was being done primarily
because state leaders were starstruck
Curt Schilling is was demigod in Rhode
Island after and all across New England
after the Red Sox won in 2004 after 86
years some legislators didn't realize
that the loan guarantee meant to
stimulate Rhode Island business was in
fact only going to stimulate one
business 38 studios after a little more
than a year in Rhode Island with monthly
expenses approaching five million
dollars and their big game released more
than a year away 38 studios began to
unravel it just disintegrated so quickly
the company actually defaulted on a
payment to the EDC and not only that
they tried to deliver a bad check the
employees didn't seem to have any idea
what was going on they all abruptly got
laid off in an email a week later the
employees found out they'd lost their
health insurance when a woman who was
pregnant whose husband worked for 38
studios went to the doctor and was told
you don't have insurance anymore others
are having to move to other parts of the
country after having just moved to Rhode
Island to relocate Donald cachoeira left
the governor's office in 2011 and was
succeeded by Republican turned
independent lincoln Chafee a vocal
opponent of the 38 studios deal from its
inception as
eh Studios defaulted on its loan
payments curt schilling hoped the state
would provide a bailout to help the
company survive
governor Chafee declined to use any more
taxpayer dollars on the foundering
company when it became clear that the
company would not survive I publicly
stated my commitment to you that my
primary goal would be to do everything
within my power to protect the taxpayers
of Rhode Island I will work to minimize
any loss of your hard-earned taxpayer
dollars
Schilling called it a 100 million dollar
i-told-you-so on the part of governor
Chafee he thinks Chafee went out of his
way to make sure 38 studios died to
prove his point after denying the
bailout governor Chafee appointed the
nonpartisan Rhode Island public
expenditure council to produce a study
that included an analysis of the
collapse of 38 studios and why the EDC
the government entity that gave the loan
completely failed to monitor the
taxpayers investment at the time that
was not a really a process in place
guidelines and principles who had not
been established by the Economic
Development Corporation the monitoring
as we found afterwards was either
non-existent or did not come up to the
board of directors of EDC north to the
governor over the year year-and-a-half
the time period before went bankrupt
they didn't necessarily have the staff
or the wherewithal to be closely
monitoring whether this company was
operating correctly whether things were
on track but you can see now in some of
the documents we've obtained here at
WPRI that they were spending four or
five million dollars a month in the
final months before the company
collapsed it would seem like that should
have raised a red flag if anyone was
looking Curt Schilling who claims to
have invested 50 million of his own
fortune in the company now says that he
is broke and may have to sell some of
the prized memorabilia from his baseball
career 38 studios assets are being
liquid in and the already economically
depressed state of Rhode Island thanks
to the interest on the 38 studios loan
is now on the hook for more than 100
million dollars in November 2012 the
state of Rhode Island filed suit against
Schilling and several former EDC members
alleging fraud racketeering and
conspiracy
Schilling says the lawsuit is political
claiming that governor Chafee did not do
enough to help the company succeed it
has launched a conversation in Rhode
Island that might not have been
happening otherwise about the
fundamentals are we getting the basics
right on being a good state for business
around is perennial elast in rankings of
business friendliness it might make the
place more gun shy about doing one-off
special deals for individual companies
where that company is picked by a
certain group of people in state
government to get some kind of deal I
think you're always going to hear now is
this in other 38 studios we're hearing
it already and I'm sure we'll be hearing
it for a lot of years
[Music]